notre intérêt est temps maintenant et
nous allons passer la semaine à
attaquer un petit village de gaulois qui
nous avait bien famille mais il s'agit
du parc astérix et qui a engagé une
grande campagne de recrutement de 1516
année elle qui travailleront d'avril à
octobre aujourd'hui ce sont les
apprentis astérix poids obélix ce que
nous découvrons avec quelques fans
balade bien sûr m tout se passait lors
d'auditions devant pareil
bonjour je suis véronique le vieil ami
a écrit des spectacles du parc astérix
et j'ai en charge de suivre la qualité
des spectacles
et le recrutement aujourd'hui concernent
d'entre eux
ils ne sont pas encore plus loin juste
candidats mais des chemises aux cols
première partie
nous sommes seuls m le spectacle
l'équipe du parc astérix fait son
casting histoire de dénicher les
talents et de tester les émotions
l
c'est une spectatrice l'édition si on
déprime
donc il faut qu'il nous reste
en plein cours l'écran est tactile
beaucoup de gentillesse
ap
premier cri une première plongée dans
l'univers gaulois
des mines
femme de celle-ci fixe donc le gaulois
n'est pas d'accord
donc ça va chauffer c'était sans
compter sur télégénique ce qui va
bien évidemment abusé de la situation
et lui donner de grandes leçons de
séduction
l'équipe au moins
la mystique
et belle lurette ces acteurs
lundi soir encore là
boeing a
vous qui le dites
bush m
son heure
au parc aussi le recrutement bat son
plein
donc cet exercice pour tester votre
capacité à renseigner le public
affaire du service
à faire durant du modèle si vous avez
l'occasion de travailler avec nous sur
une des boutiques et des restaurants du
parc par exemple interpellation le
numéro 15
ce type d'équipement
il critique les attractions hippiques a
coûté
pilote de manège pizzaïolo tous sont
aussi mises en condition quant au bâton
ce qui positionne la rambarde au niveau
de la cure l'accord patron afp
on connaît la suite d'un corner
cliquez ici
après tout le monde jusqu'à temps que
la barre 61 cents
mais il existe d'autres sélectionnés
dans un parc d'attraction c'est un peu
le pied à paris
n y fait
il parle
l'armée régulière
demain matin
l'enquêté penalty
voilà pour l'histoire de la formule 1
% layton a pas cité je me rappelle il a
également rappelé m
didier de 2000 et lieu de deux
je elles n'étaient pas poursuivis
la même semaine
cela nécessite pas de relève
alors je vais vous apprenez partition
qui fait partie du spectacle assurance
fous rires
c'est donc la petite comédie musicale
de développement après les
improvisations et le chant la dentiste
l'audition tout type de système
battu à mort alors qu'il était parti
le temps passe vite et bien michelin
mais en pleine tête
voilà alea jacta est moins minimes 10
mais une équipe du smur
le jury n'a peut-être pas encore plus
de charme de la voix sur ange porri que
ce missile déjà son idée fixe sur les
comédiens sélectionnés
à voir donc
à arras
la route
il traversait repartent la tête est un
fait et pour que ce n'était pas des
pieds noirs france est en danger jed
hoyer nicolas bertholon la suite bien
sûr demain